maybe to you it looks like efficiency
but to me it looked like
a Gordon was not even trying there was a
um a relaxed aspect to the whole thing
so maybe it had to do with saving energy
but he made it look very easy yeah and
he made the the path to submission look
very easy so here the first match
against an opponent that again looks
bigger than him
okay I'll just give an initial comment
here
um first you'll see that Gordon elected
to sit to the bottom position
um the hardest work in submission
grappling is when two athletes take the
standing position and just for takedowns
uh that's where most of the energy gets
burned up so working on the idea of
Energy Efficiency let's go out and we we
chose to sit into God position and then
start looking to access our opponents
back because of our opponent's hit
position a far side arm drag makes a lot
of sense Gordon's able to beat the arm
and quickly get behind his opponent now
the question is going to be getting into
a scoring position it's too early to
score at this point but we're just
concerned at this stage of just energy
expenditure make the other guy work
harder than us so uh Gordon did I'm
dragged to the back and I was working on
the hooks
um the hooks are not particularly
important here he'll use it just to get
stability on his opponent but um
interestingly his opponent here had an
interesting strategy too which was to
occupy bottom Turtle position and uh and
look to get to the critical five-point
Demarcus sorry our five minute
demarcation point where points began
begin to get scored his idea I believe
I'm speculating here based on his
actions was to keep Gordon at Bay in a
defensive Turtle position until a five
minute Mark occurred in which case he
would Shake Gordon off walk away and
force a takedown battle how many people
are are comfortable in that and what do
you think about the defensive tournament
position versus always trying to come
back to guard the total position is the
second bottom position of units so many
people only associate God position with
bottom position and Jiu-Jitsu that's
that's naive there's two there's guard
position and turtle position now as a
general rule guard position offers a
much much greater variety of attacking
options than total position does
but that's not to say turtle position
absolutely Can Be
an Effective bottom possession you can
work effectively from there so there's
some case to be made that to wait out
five minutes the turtle might be I mean
I I personally think it it get against
Gordon Ryan I mean I admire the fellas
courage I I
um it's not easy but there was a logic
to what he was doing uh people think oh
he just got his back taken so easily but
he did have a strategy now did he pick
the right person to use that strategy
against probably not
um so Gordon is able to uh break the
turtle down get one hook in
at which point I I is this becoming an
uh extremely controlling position with
Gordon in the back at which point is
there are you happy with where at this
point uh it just started to dawn on me
at this point this guy actually had a
strategy which was to maintain a a prone
position that he's in now and then Shake
golden off after the five minute Mark so
um uh once that became obvious and I was
uh now excited to look at the clock and
how close we are if you can take it up
to five minutes
right now this guy's only intention is
to stop going from strangling him and
finish
okay now the guy's trying to go up in
vertical uh freeze it there now do you
see how he's taking his elbows off the
mat and turtle position in Jiu-Jitsu
there's only one reason you take your
elbows off the mat from Turtle position
that's the stand up so now it's it's
clear at this point what his actual
strategy is it's to get up for
sustaining confrontation when a takedown
battle and be Gordon by points so he did
have a strategy now our counter strategy
is always based around the power half
Nelson this is a common move in the
sport of wrestling and it's a great way
to break people down as they try to
stand up Jordan's so heavy yeah I mean
Gordon is a master of it and so there's
a power Nelson that Gordon has on him as
the as the elbows are off the ground and
knees are off the ground he's going to
return his opponent to the mat and as
you can see he's successful in doing so
and now it's clear what demand strategy
is so I'm calling to Gordon to break him
down to a hip you put a man on a hip he
can't stand up according successfully
does it traps the shoulder using that
one-on-one grip with his right hand puts
him down to his shoulder and a hip that
means standing up is no longer an option
for his opponent now Gordon goes in he's
already scoring because of the uh the
total position that he's in his
shoulders his opponent stays down on his
shoulder now Gordon's responsibility to
start looking for the strangle hold his
opponent has basic defensive structures
disciplined with his chin keeps the chin
down Gordon is a master of tying up
defensive arms and penetrating under the
chin to get to a strangle and you'll see
that shortly
there's the trapping of the arm
notice that no Advanced uh
uh groups were required it was just a
spontaneous trap just the penetration of
the neck
so the arm was trapped with the leg Yeah
so now he's only got one defensive arm
and he's just taking that away with his
left hand he gets a one-handed strangle
for the Finish
and it looks like not much energy was
expanded during very little yeah so
that's a as the torment got off to a
very smooth start very energy
expenditure no injuries and a submission
win
does that
there's a kind of certain look to Gordon
of that could be interpreted as
nervousness that was an incorrect
interpretation yes okay so there's a uh
what do you interpret as nervous
Behavior
well this is uh part of me is trolling
but
sometimes on the surface confident
Behavior can look like uh
almost like anger
and there's a
Gordon's face had a like a vulnerability
to it almost like uh when you go to
judge confidence don't look at the face
look at the extremities of the body yeah
that's where the truth comes out you see
it in body language and the further from
the face and cheers the more honest the
body becomes
look at the feet and the hands
well there were I mean that's when you
see if people are nervous or not he was
very relaxed uh in the extremities
that's true see you look more confident
in this in this than anything what what
are you thinking about what I what uh
what's going through your head here
all right this is the same stuff are you
are you intimidated by the the two
Meatheads one in a suit and tie or are
you not thinking about that at all I
know now for me it's just about okay
what's the most efficient positive
Victory against this particular opponent
it's just okay I've done my job I've
taken them through a uh an extensive
fight camp that prepared them for every
conceivable situation that they're in uh
I've run an efficient warm-up their body
temperature is perfect the elasticity in
the muscles is perfect
um
my main role when I corner
is I avoid what most people do when they
Corner which is to be a cheerleader most
cornermen they're not cornermen they're
cheerleaders they're there to express
some kind of emotional support to their
training partners and or their their
student
sometimes they're even worse than
cheerleaders they express their own
emotional fears
as the match goes on
um
I always believe that 99.5 percent of
the job of the trainer is done the coach
is done
when the athlete steps their foot on the
mat
at that point
you shouldn't need me at all everything
I needed to tell you should have been
not just told you but imprinted into you
remember this fifteen thousand people in
that crowd for half of the match you're
not going to hear a word that I can say
there's too much noise but you'll hear
my voice inside your head
because you've heard it so many times
over the last 14 weeks you're sick of
hearing it at that point
in their program know what to do
um
so I'm I'm usually
pretty confident I'm also very confident
that even in worst case scenarios they
can have effective Solutions because
they train those worst case scenarios
every single day in the gym
and so in part you're there to have a
front row seat
to analyze what happened so you can take
that to the next match the biggest
danger in athlete faces is tunnel vision
sometimes they will
Hit Upon A Certain move or strategy and
just say I'm going to go with this when
there's much easier Alternatives but
because they're so focused on the
alternative they've chosen they get this
tunnel vision and just focus only on
that the most constructive thing the
corner man can do is alert them to the
presence of time which is very important
in ADCC match because they're all the
scoring is structured by time and to
alleviate problems associated with
tunnel vision that okay you're doing
this
but if you just did this it'll be so
much easier so that's the main goal so
here uh this was one of several
anticipated matches against the second
one against Victor Hugo
which is a very tough opponent
and uh again this was a situation where
golden was considerably outweighed by
his opponent so the main thing here was
efficiency his opponent elected to avoid
the standing position by jumping into
God so now guard yeah yeah Gordon would
be in top position this time he has a
very good closed guard but unfortunately
Gordon has very good God passing so um
uh he he's an excellent guard player
very talented but Gordon is renowned as
the imminent God Pastor in the world
today so
um it's a tall order to hold Gordon off
for a 10 minute match is there something
you can say about this guard passing
Gordon is making it look very easy it's
middle distance guard passing here
um he eventually passes to mount I
believe
in a very uh again why don't you run
through the sequence where he gets
mounted this uh there's a couple I
believe he gets mounted twice as I'm not
I just back just a little bit further
yeah
so he's trying to one one arm under yeah
this is a stacking position now normally
we always insist on the idea of getting
advantageous angle first controlling the
feet and getting angle
um but there's a height advantage that
Victor Hugo has here and the length of
his legs
um means that he can play very very wide
with his leg so getting an advantageous
angle might be difficult in these
circumstances it often makes sense to go
right up the middle
um now Gordon could just go back for the
legs because the legs Victor Hugo's legs
are so far apart at this point that you
could easily isolate a leg and attack
there but Gordon wanted to uh to show
off his passing prowess very often he'll
go into a match and say okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna show this skill and he'll
often use it as a demonstration of um
techniques he teaches in instructional
videos so he wanted to show that he
could pass the mount readily on a world
champion like this part here
this little step okay I just freeze it
right there go back one step okay you
can clearly see that all of his
opponents defensive frames are built on
his opponent's left hand side so
everything is defense on the on the left
but you can see this comes at a price
and that price is back exposure on the
right hand side you can literally see
his opponents back on that side so
Gordon's whole uh game is to to place
sufficient pressure that you the
opponent overcompensates on the side of
pressure just to set up a quick switch
across to the other side there's the
vulnerability there's the back exposure
his opponent has to put his back on the
ground switches back that's a world
champion right there on bottom who does
a good job of recovering from the first
danger but unfortunately Gordon has been
here a thousand times and kicks out a
little little step and so you see
there's two changes in Direction left
right in a very short period of time
that people find very very hard to keep
up with now his opponent builds up to an
album he's looking to to create more and
more space from here but Gordon counters
by just stepping over the hips it's just
when and you you feel like every move
he's doing the right things the man on
bottom is doing well he's doing the
right things but the other guys just
been here too many times and it's just a
half second ahead of every decision
going up in the elbow
and Gordon makes it look so easy here
with the it's it almost seems like uh
Victor's out but this turning of the
hips with the arm over the opponent's
back he's able to bring him back down
and get and Gordon takes mount
notice how golden is never satisfied
with the mounted position itself he's
only satisfied with an extended mounted
position with the elbow comes up over
the shoulder line
he only then does he show there's a
there's a little bit of relief right
there right right
there's a little bit of a relief now
that's that's the look of a man who's
just proved the point
oh yeah this is very Michael Jordan like
sticks his tongue out so yeah I mean
there's no points at the stage he really
is going for submission
and then this this happens again
is this the match that wasn't Gordon was
the only match where Gordon didn't uh
finish his opponent by submission
was this very frustrating for him was
there uh it's actually interesting that
when he came off the mat
um uh he was visibly frustrated he
wanted to uh to get a finish and
um I think he was more upset about not
finishing Victor Hugo than he was
delighted by winning his two gold medals
um
uh so I think that says a lot about the
perfectionism of Gordon Ryan most people
would be thrilled to beat one of the
great Grapplers of this generation
decisively in this fashion but he was uh
he was not happy
and so this is a Gordon's third match
against uh Souza Roosevelt Souza now
there's another guy who's yeah very big
uh different because now we're on to the
second day
um your listeners should be aware that
the event occurs over a two-day period
so the previous two matches occurred on
Saturday now we're into Sunday now this
puts a different context on things if we
could just freeze it right there maybe
go back one step
um now we're on Sunday morning and the
idea is that Gordon will be fighting the
biggest fight of his life late that
afternoon so now we're into the idea of
energy conservation okay it's okay to
have two hard matches on on Saturday
because you get to rest on Saturday
night but now Gordon has to beat two
people
back to back and save energy for the
biggest fight of his life on Sunday uh
late Sunday afternoon so now the
emphasis is on a quick win and you can
see Gordon Ryan
certainly delivers on this now when you
go to entangle your opponent's legs the
basic choice you have is between
straight ashigurami and cross ashigurami
um
in the last five years cross ashigrami
has proven to be statistically the more
important of the two
um and as a result many people have
forgotten the value of straight
ashigurami leg based leg locks and
undervalued them uh Gordon has
outstanding heel hooks from both
straight and cross positions and his
opponent was probably more concerned
about the danger of a cross ashigurami
left the the right leg uh undefended for
far too long and as a result Gordon goes
into
a very classical
ashigrama you would normally expect to
see from five or six years ago and gets
a very very quick finish so lifts his
opponent
there's the ashigurami the entanglement
of one of his opponent's legs were two
of his now he's got to turn and expose
his opponent's heel so there's an
initial off balance to the left to get a
defensive reaction the opponent
overcompensates exposes his heel and
then there's the submission
being broken here Gordon has a
absolutely ferocious outside here okay
until you felt it it's um it's quite
different so the the opponent probably
before he even felt the heel hook felt
the control and that it's yeah it's I
think he's screwed there yeah he doesn't
even want the yeah when someone has a
someone who knows what they're doing
gets a bite on your leg like that you
feel it deep inside your knee and Ankle
tendons immediately and um
it's there's a sense in which you almost
tap
uh he got a couple of TAPS almost almost
like as if they're early because people
came out to what's happening this guy
tapped early he's like no he knew yeah
yeah
he knew that uh late would be a big
problem
got it so this is within within within
like 30 seconds within 10 seconds he was
within 10 seconds so this was a
excellent example of someone saying Okay
I'm going to conserve energy with a
short match I'm not just going to go
down into a neutral position I'm going
to directly pull into a leg lock attack
from standing position you don't see
that much in heavyweight divisions
that's something you see more in the
lightweight divisions
so we got to go to the final matches uh
of Gordon's within his division which I
think
um as opposed to uh facing Philippe Pena
who lost to Nikki Rod he's Mickey Road
had a great match against Felipe Pena
um uh and uh past Felipe pan as God I
think only the second person in 80cc
competition to accomplish that I believe
with the with the body luck uh it
started as a body long but he converted
to half guard top head numb and uh
passed out of half guard top chest to
chest I think I listened to uh uh Craig
Jones sort of interview summarizing what
happened agcc and he briefly mentioned
that uh Nikki Rob might have
the best body lock capacity he's ever
felt so like they're very very good with
the ball the way to face I think you're
right is don't get him don't let him get
the body lock but there's any problem if
you stand up he's a good wrestler so he
is there's a dilemma that like you have
to sit down to God but that goes into
his body lot but then if you stand up
now you go into his wrestling skill so
it's a great dilemma that he has and
that that's what uh
in in facing and facing
uh Nikki Rod going around here chooses
to
um yeah if if you look at the limbs
there's a relaxation there we should
also explain some things here uh this is
a finals match so instead of being 10
minutes long it's 20 minutes long with
the option of a 20 minute overtime so
this could potentially be a 40-minute
match so you can see why the ADCC people
were very concerned about Gordon doing
this match because what if what if this
match had gone 40 minutes and then an
exhausted Gordon Ryan has to go out to
fight Andre Galvan who's fresh and and
ready to Maul them and then top of that
is former two former teammates who know
each other's game very well so there was
a high likelihood of most people's minds
that this would go the distance because
you know when you train with each other
for years every single day in the gym
seven days a week you you get to know
each other's tricks
um one big problem here for Nikki Rod is
that uh his body lock guard passing game
which is this main whiffer on the ground
was taught to him by us so it's not like
we're gonna be taken by surprise by it
so that that must have been figuring in
his mind do you think uh psychologically
for Gordon and psychologically for
nicaran it's tough so for him with that
body lock for example do you think it's
tough for him to know what to do here uh
it's tough because he would have
remembered the outcome of the training
sessions it's hard to go up against a
guy who
used to dominate you in training and
then say okay I'm going to beat him in
competition again you shut all that off
because it's tough man memory is memory
you can't lie to yourself you know what
do you think about competition instead
of there there's been a lot of Olympics
bring this out there's been a lot of big
upsets at the Olympics there's something
where people find something in them I
mean Judo
is it is a different sport than
grappling in Judo there's much more room
for upset because a mistake in Judo
will have ramifications that will be
felt within half a second like if you if
you take the wrong grip and Judo you can
be thrown in half a second and there's
no recovery if your two Shoulders hit
the map the momentum it's over it's done
um
in Jiu Jitsu you could especially in
ADCC where there's no points in the
first five minutes you could get taken
down and mounted by your opponent and
still win like you can recover from a
bad start in Judo boxing kickboxing
MMA you get hit there's no recovery time
you just get swarmed on and um Jiu Jitsu
is a much more forgiving sport where you
can make a series of blunders and you
just recover from them you don't make a
series of blunders and boxing you're
unconscious so that there's the blunder
case but there's also been just people
where it's their day
I mean again maybe it's romanticized in
the notion but there's been some epic
performances in Russ in Olympic
wrestling in Olympic Judo as an example
Satoshi Ichi he had a 2008 performance
we talked about all Japan and all that
kind of stuff but the Olympics he
destroyed uh everybody on this path to
the Olympic gold medal and that's when
Teddy Romero was also competing he got
the bronze so I mean that
now you could say he was at that time
the best in the world also but he I mean
yeah but I think it would be very fair
to say he was the best in the world I he
think about the people he beat to win
three old Japan championships like he
beat because in a way uh he beat kg
Suzuki they were Olympic Champions like
he was already so you don't believe him
he will
I don't believe that a person can walk
on stage and be better than what they
are supposed to be you you have a skill
level it's set in stone this is your
skill level you don't just go on stage
and suddenly your school level gets here
what you do have is a situation where
you have a skill level okay
another opponent has a higher skill
level but he runs into confidence issues
so that he only uses a small percentage
of his actual skills and then he will
fall below someone who is technically
lower on the skill scale than he is that
can happen
but you can't just magically acquire
skills yeah but they're able to fall in
confidence yes so the question becomes
who manages that four best and that can
create upsets absolutely so you don't
think Gordon could have fallen in
confidence against the former teammate
when the pressure is so high there was
just no basis for a fall to occur you
said he doesn't have confidence issues
is uh what do you attributing that to
that's because he never loses in the gym
I mean there's there's nothing in the
there's no experience that he's had that
would make him say I shouldn't be this
confident so it's the physical uh it's
like uh like we talked about mental
preparation but don't get me wrong if
Gordon lost 20 matches in a row of
course his confidence would drop because
experience is now
there's going to be a psychological uh
dissonance between
uh his experience his recent experience
and what he believes okay if you believe
you're best in the world you just lost
20 matches at some point reality is
going to break in but if you're just
never losing in competition
dominating people in the gym
then there's nothing in your experience
that would shake your confidence can I
ask you this just in a small tangent why
is Gordon Ryan so good
so we're looking at you've trained a lot
of special athletes you're a special
human being yourself
I could just look at human history
there's a lot of
not a lot there's some special humans it
seems like Gordon Ryan is one of them I
I totally agree with that can you try to
like dissect that's what I mean when I
said I had many students but only one
golden Ryan like I've taught many many
people but they don't all have his skill
level so there's an obvious elephant in
the room here okay what distinguishes
him from from other athletes
great question I'll try and give an
answer
more than anyone else that I've ever
toured he has a memory
for things that were taught to him
he has an ability to recall information
that is extraordinary compared with
other people in the room so that's
definitely a big part of it
secondly he has a pride in technique and
Technical prowess
that will not allow him to settle for
anything less than Perfection and he
will hate himself when there is
imperfection
so there is a love of excellence and a
hatred of anything less than than
excellence
he has
an ability
to pull the trigger
when opportunity arises
which is truly extraordinary
many people know what to do but when the
moment comes
they back off
and they'll doubt themselves
if Gordon sees the opportunity the
trigger pulls every time
so can I just just link on that
absolutely there's a few times where he
gets a little bit of an advantage and he
just chases it to get a big like uh with
Andre gaval you know you get it's like
uh there's a dance and you get one step
ahead and he's able to chase that you
know get a little glimmer of the back
and he's able to chase that all the way
to back control so that that is that
kind of the trigger that you're
referring to yes it runs deeper than
that too it's the idea that good
athletes are greedy athletes
okay when they see a small opportunity
they try and get a as big a bite of it
as possible so that the manager that we
always have in training if you can see
the bag you can take the back and if
Gordon sees an inch of your back
you know that's the duration he's going
to be going if your far shoulder is
within an inch of the floor he's going
to remounting you uh if your shoulder
comes off the floor he'll be on your
back on the other side
um he's a maximalist with opportunity
he's not satisfied with oh let me get a
good enough outcome it's like I want the
maximal outcome so when you combine all
these things together an ability to
recall information
which is just
far superior to anyone else I've ever
coached
um an ability to
work in the training room towards not
just good technique but excellent
technique
the conference to pull the trigger
whenever the opportunity arises a
maximalist mindset where
It's never enough to have a good enough
outcome it's always got to be the best
possible outcome
and
The Fifth Element which I believe is
very very important
is
extraordinary depth
in his technical prowess
in particular with regards his defense
of Acumen everyone looks at Gordon and
focuses on his offensive prowess because
they see him dominate other athletes
but what they don't see is what I see
every day in the gym where he works from
impossibly Bad defensive positions
someone locked in on a full heel hook
on his body on a full Duty guitar me
Amber
in a complete pin mounted with Gordon's
two arms stretched out over his head in
what looks like a hopeless position
and Gordon will work in these positions
and of course because it's such a bad
position sometimes he'll have to tap
but he just works so relentlessly in
these bad positions that when he steps
on stage
he say
if this guy got the worst possible
position on me there's nothing he could
do with it and within 30 seconds I could
turn it around on him and win this match
um that gives his game
an overall breadth and depth which is
very very hard to deal with it means
there's no obvious weak point where you
can just say okay I'm going to attack
him here and use this strategy to to
beat them
um
and that goes back to uh his confidence
that
the reason why most people lack
confidence is because they fear about
bad outcomes okay if if you're a strong
um guard player
you've got an excellent guide but you're
terrified of leg logs and your opponent
has strong leg logs you will shut down
your own guard
and won't play as freely and well as you
normally do because you're afraid of the
leglock danger you'll pull your feet in
You'll Play a very
conservative guard game
but if you had extremely adept
leg lock defense then you just play with
all the uh the confidence you normally
do from from guard position
um Gordon puts himself in that situation
he's so defensively sound
that it translates into his offensive
confidence
when you talk about memory recall which
is interesting I I can't help but see
parallels between him and Magnus Carlson
who's a chess player who's the number
one in the world
the arguably the best ever certainly the
best ever if you just look absolute
numbers the chess has the luxury of
having a rating
uh which you can't have it cannot have
in Jiu Jitsu because it's a game of
human chess chess is just a board game
so you can actually calculate the
probability that you could win so he has
the highest ELO rating uh ever and he's
maintained that rating he can without
competing against
the number two in the world he could
just prove that he's the number one in
the world for many years uh anyway
there's uh certain similarities one's
ability to re recall so memory recall of
information is fascinatingly good and
the other one is not so much a love for
Perfection which is something you
mentioned but yeah the flip side of that
which is what you also mentioned is the
hate of imperfection uh now in the case
of Magnus
it almost uh creates a level of anxiety
for him that's almost destructive
so the thing he seems to hate the most
is imperfection against people he knows
are worse than him
so the thing he loves is competing
against people that are close to skill
level or the favorite is people who are
might actually be better than him
especially in certain positions he loves
competing against them he hates
competing against people that are
um still from the perspective of
everyone else
uh what are called super Grand Masters
so top three in the world but he knows
he's much better than them and the
anxiety of being not perfect against
those people that's why that's why he I
don't know if you're paying attention
but he stepped away he's not going to
defend his world championship
uh because he hates the anxiety of
playing people worse than him
interesting he figures they would
somehow make him look bad or no he just
for him at least the language he uses is
just not fun
and he likes having fun it's to him it
was fun to win no matter the skill level
the world championship the first time
but then defending it is a very grueling
process
is
um
with classical chess you play these many
hours it could be seven hour long games
and
uh on on top of that he really hates the
fact that it's only I forget what it is
but it's single digit number of games he
says it's it's low sample
so uh I can't
I would like to play 20 30 40 50 games
if we're going to do it this way but
then they're too long it's going to take
too long so he's really emphasizes the
the the fun of it and the clear
demonstration of who's the best now
chess
is an interesting game it's probably
different than grappling because it's
been played for centuries so there's
this giant body of people that are
playing it like there's other Gordon
Ryan's out there imagine a world where
there's multiple Gordon Ryan's or
something like that just different
dimensions but uh you have like sharks
everywhere and so there there is fun to
be had even at the very very very very
very top but the the memory recall is
the thing that stands out and the hate
of imperfection uh more intense than
anybody else in the game fascinating
that takes us back to the final ah yes
so uh here Gordon is facing uh Nikki Rod
former training Pana and
um again the intention here is this has
to be put in the context that Gordon
will be fighting the greatest ACC
Grappler of all time in a few hours
after this so what we're looking for is
a uh a quick
resolution
um still the shortest possible match now
there's a complicating Factor here Nikki
Rod was a wrestler before he was a jiu
jitsu player
on paper
the way his route to win is via
wrestling is not going to be able to
um
submit Gordon Ryan and he's not going to
be able to pass his guard so he has to
win by wrestling
in the 80cc finals you cannot set to
guard so the the approach that Gordon
used earlier that we saw on video cannot
be used in the finals Gordon must
wrestle his opponent
so
on the way out
uh Gordon and I were talking and we'd
had discussions obviously during the
camp what's the appropriate thing to do
here
and there had been some
matches earlier in the event where it
was becoming obvious that stalling
was being heavily punished by referees
so
I said to Gordon on the way out just
give him your leg
let him take you down because in the
first 10 minutes of the finals takedowns
don't score anything well there are no
there are no means of scoring the first
10 minutes but you can't set the guard
that will be that will award you a
negative point so I said just let Nikki
Royal take you down and he's like Nikki
Rod's not going to take the bait and I
said if he doesn't they'll call on for
stalling
and so
and and then Craig Jones also commented
after the fact is I don't know why Nikki
took the beat
um so if we see the start of the match
you see Gordon comes out and offers her
leg now it's not that you know Nikki
Wright is smart he knows what's
happening here and uh what's he going to
do store for 10 minutes and get like
five restoring calls put against them so
Gordon gives them the takedown that way
they go to the ground immediately with
no effort and the match now favors
Gordon because Gordon is
uh significantly more skilled on the
ground
um
the question is how can we make this
match as short as possible and as is so
often the case the answer comes back to
legs
so uh for people just listening to this
Gordon is in an open guard and nicarad
appears to be trying to keep his hips
away from Gordon's legs yes the big
Nikki Rod knows there's a danger here so
he's elected to go to his knees that
will set up his favorite body lock
passes and it will in some ways mitigate
some of the dangers associated with leg
locks so Gordon's whole thing is how am
I going to get my body weight underneath
them here's a choice between linear
entries where he enters between his
opponent's knees and circular entries
where he inverts and Spins underneath
this opponent to get under a center of
gravity is is there a way for somebody
to try to get a body lock without giving
going an opportunity to get under under
them uh well the body lock is an
excellent way to shut down leg lock
entries if you can get to the body lock
but you can see Gordon's very very
disciplined with his elbow and knee
position elbows and knees are working in
a position where it's very very hard for
his opponent to access his waste
foreign
either across the hip or in front of the
shoulder sorry his knee is either in
front of the shoulder or in front of the
hip and we're one minute into the match
and just if I were to look at the video
player here it appears that the match is
over soon so uh
so I guess Nikki Wright is facing this I
need to get close in order to do the uh
the body lock and the closer you get the
more danger there is
uh to let Gordon get uh under you and
get the leg control
foreign
to get close here Gordon's going to try
and get his head underneath his opponent
make a circular entry into the legs
he's clearing his opponent's head out of
the way by faking the arm drag on the
far side the first move that he used
against his uh first opponent earlier in
the tournament and there's the leg spins
underneath it
go circular rotates through gets his
body weight underneath his opponent okay
now he's going to trip him down to the
mat now uh I believe Nigeria tries to
pull out his foot here
and Craig also said that nicarad has
gotten used to being able to pull that
foot out from anybody and that he was
very surprised at the grip
that that Gordon was able to actually
hold on
so I just want to comment I'm I'm just
I'm just parroting commentary um if you
look at what's happening here from the
internet uh just if you just freeze it
you'll see that Gordon like any good leg
Locker will always treat his opponent's
foot like a knot at the end of the Rope
just as you slide down a rope if there's
a knot at the end your hand will catch
yeah so too with the human leg when they
go to extract by pulling you just keep
your fist is close to your shoulder
shoulder as possible and narrow the Gap
the foot will always catch the failure
that many people have is they let their
hand drift away from their own shoulder
and so there's room for the foot to
extract but you'll see Gordon's
extremely disciplined with thumb close
to his own shoulder which creates a
situation that's very very hard just to
simply pull your foot out you're you're
focusing on the knot of the foot yeah
also it's very early in the match
there's very little sweat both athletes
are still pretty dry
now Gordon has to climb the leg
and now he's already captured his
opponent's shoelace there's the heel
exposure coming up Nikki Rod already
knows things are getting bad
and there's the win actually the comment
I made I guess was from a little bit
earlier there was an earlier time where
Nikki while I was trying to pull out the
foot and the Gordon's able to hold on to
the knot
um which which is interesting
now that was uh
a brilliant day's work by Gordon Ryan he
said two matches against opponents
considerably bigger and stronger than
himself
and uh the time of the two matches can
be measured in
I think less than two minutes so he's
he's done what he's set out to do no
injuries no exhaustion he's beaten four
guys back to back all of whom are
excellent athletes with minimal energy
expenditure and he's ready to go on to
his super fight
so uh and that's against uh one of the
greatest arguably for a long time you
know uh really really up there uh
Jiu-Jitsu practitioners competitors
grappling no geek competitors of all
time which is Andre goval yes Andre
gavals uh almost certainly at this point
the the greatest ADCC competitor of all
time he won more Super fights than
anyone else by a landslide
so I if I may just read a few words
you've written on Instagram about this
match about Andre gaval on greatness how
great you become in any given Endeavor
will always be assessed by the degree of
difficulty of the barriers you have to
overcome to get to the top just as the
lion became king of the jungle not by
living among sheep but by dominating a
world of elephants hyenas Buffalo
leopards crocodiles so too the greatness
of an athlete will be determined not
just by his own ability but by the
greatness of the athletes he faces thus
in his quest for greatness Gordon Ryan
owes a debt to the greatness of his
toughest opponent Andre galvao and you
go on to sing him Praises so and that
introduces this match you know there was
a interesting moment I didn't even
um
listen to the wars exchanged but because
I had the great Fortune of sitting next
to hacho crazy there was this uh
uh fascinating moment before the match
and I can't believe Gordon has
sufficiently relaxed to do this but he
walked up to uh haja Gracie and had a
discussion what do you think you Face
Hunter Goa before what are your
suggestions and they've talked to back
and forth they brainstormed ideas like
minutes before the match and it was just
a beautiful moment of like I don't know
like like Tiger Woods and Michael Jordan
talking to each other something like
that I mean I I wonder how much
brainstorming there really was or and
how much was it just kind of um
ins like spiritual inspiration or
something like that yeah the I think
it's more spiritual inspiration he looks
up to algerism as a uh uh Hodges a very
close friend a mentor of mine so I
always tell my athletes look to hodger
as your example this is a guy who
always fought for the Finish he tried to
express the the highest ideal of Jiu
Jitsu which is control leading to
submission and every match he was ever
in he even lost matches on tactics
against people that he could easily have
defeated if he adopted a different
tactic but he always insisted on Victory
by submission it defined his career made
him who who he was and I always try to
have my athletes emulate him
so what was the strategy going into this
match what were you thinking were you
okay uh for Andre Galvan
he
hit there's a sense in which Andre gavon
had to fight literally the perfect match
to win this okay this this is a match
that's going to be 20 minutes long
um and potentially 40 minutes long
um
Andre gomon cannot win by submission
Gordon's submission
dominance here is is just too great
uh it would be exceedingly difficult for
him to win on the ground uh Gordon's
ground positional game is just too
advanced and so for Andre Galvan he had
to win if he was going to win it was
going to be in a standing wrestling
exchange where most people assist him as
having a measure of superiority over
Gordon Ryan
the problem is
that
it's hard
to just keep a potentially 40 minute
match on the ground sorry off the ground
that whole time it's it's very very
difficult indeed so he would have had to
fight literally the perfect tactical
match to make it happen and he would
have to do it without getting called
with stalling points
um
Gordon has the luxury that if at any
point they go to the ground he has
complete dominance but Gordon too has a
problem that he can't pull guard without
being penalized and uh if Andre Galvan
can play this tactical game of forcing
Gordon to pull guard
and then
staying at a distance where he doesn't
he's doing enough action not to get
called for stalling but not so much to
engage with the dangerous Gordon Ryan on
the ground then it's feasible he could
have won
but it would have been as I said it
would have required the most perfect
application and integration of technique
and tactics
that that he's capable of
how much intimidation was here
was there uh or are these assets already
beyond that uh when you say intimidation
be more precise
do you think there is some degree if
you're just to empathize with Andre
gaval do you think there's some degree
in which Gordon was in his head
um because of the Trash Talk leading up
to certain events because of the level
of dominance that Gordon has shown in
this competition and in uh
months and years leading up to it also
the fact that Andre gaval is also a
coach of a large team so there's some
pressure to demonstrate to the team
that the old line still got it yeah
um I can't speak for Andre but uh I know
for Gordon
it's hard to be intimidated when you
know the other guy has no method of
finishing you
it's it just takes so much pressure off
when you just go in this end there's
literally no way this guy can finish me
um and there's no way this guy can pin
and control me
I can't be finished I can't be pinned
and controlled
the only way I can lose this
is if this guy plays a tactical game
so in his best case scenario
I lose my Tactical
by a tactical game but from Andre's
perspective it's like if I make one
screw up this kid could finish me
like it's you can see which way the
intimidation game goes
now for the start things get interesting
here we've already said if you can just
freeze it right there
Andre's only real realistic part to
Victory is standing grappling okay that
would require him to take Gordon down
presumably multiple times after the
first 10 minutes and not be taken down
at all by Gordon so it's a tall order
it's possible but difficult
and here's where things get interesting
I told Gordon before the match
just go out and offer him the leg same
we did with Nikki rod
and that's where things get interesting
I must say that I loved what Andre
Galvan did at the start of this match
he's a little crazy here this is there
was just so much energy in the room at
this point that his hand finding God oh
for people just listening there's uh
there's a bit of hard slapping yeah that
could be considered a strike that's fine
it's um there was just a lot of electric
atmosphere in the room so now things
settle down a little bit
um but here's where things get
interesting Andre
throws the whole tactical game out the
window right from the start
he goes for the takedown Gordon doesn't
try to fight the takedown because it's
in his interests to go to the ground but
this I love this about Andre he's
literally like [ __ ] you kid
like let's see how good your ground game
is yeah so he shoots the takedown
um and Gordon accepts it obviously
because it's to his advantage to accept
it
but I love the fact that Andre was like
I'm not even going to try and stole this
out I'm just going to bang there it is
so he's like okay let's see what you got
kid they say you good on the ground
let's see what you [ __ ] got and I
love that about Andre
unfortunately he's entered the uh The
Hornet's Nest now what happened there
real quick because that was very Gordon
immediately went into ashigrami not just
any ashigurami but ashirami was holding
both legs so it was an open guard and he
scooted forward oh wow that's really
nice so it's against the legs now he
dominates the space between the knees so
there's a guaranteed straight out sugar
Army here
he split the knees against Andre galvao
like effortlessly right there
wow
so already Gordon's in his preferred
domain now so he's starting to off
balance his opponent he's looking for
reaction to get heel exposure he does
get heel exposure Andre's uh does a good
job of monitoring defeat to try and
reduce the braking pressure but the The
Brute fact is it's in Gordon's realm now
this is this is where he has all the
advantage so um and the match is going
to be 20 minutes of in Gordon's realm
it's going to be a very very tall order
foreign
was there a moment here
again Gordon's on the legs
are you impressed that Andre was able to
get out from this corner I would expect
this on Andre's been preparing for this
for two years and um uh he remember
Andre has gone against some of the
greatest uh leg Locus and grappling
before and Prevail so he's he's not
naive you know he knows how to defend
himself
um the big problem is that he's going to
create defensive reactions which lead
into other aspects of Gordon's game in
particular back exposure so here uh
ashigurami goes to like a single leg
type of position where Gordon Runs to
Andre's back
now it has to return them to the mat the
most efficient way to do so is always
courtesy of foot sweeping so he pulls
out a DIY from the back to sweep him
down to the man
and now Gordon's on top and this
is a serious problem for any Grappler in
the world once Gordon gets top position
he's just relentless
but just getting Andre gavar's good just
getting the guard back all of that is
great there's also a sense here in which
Gordon is pacing it too just to
physically fatigue an opponent
foreign
but not rushing it
now what Gordon's looking for here is
complete Chester Chase contact
he's getting very close to it now
and once he gets chest to chased on an
opponent in top position past one of his
opponent's knees it's going to be
awfully awfully difficult for an
opponent to recover
what is he waiting for here is the this
pressure here over time he just wears
you out yeah it's part of a campaign of
attrition of pressure over time now he's
creating a situation where he's he's
either going to get back exposure or
Mount exposure and either way is pretty
much fatal when you're dealing with
Gordon
um Andre elected to to go the route of
back exposure
now Gordon got the body triangle is on
his back
and now it's uh now there's one physical
problem here that's uh that Andre Galvan
has a neck like a bull and um he's a
very short and very thick neck so
penetrating under the chin for a
strangle can be a real problem he also
has extremely well developed shoulders
and upper arms so when the head comes
down and the shoulders go up there's
very little real estate to work with
with regards to strangle holds so Gordon
in time will trap one of his opponent's
arms with his legs in order to take away
one of those strong defensive arms there
you can see the arm has been trapped and
now you can see nobody towards the
strangle
and now here is still difficult it's
still difficult but um things are
looking good there's still a
considerable amount of time left on the
clock Gordon as well ahead on points so
all the pressure all the Tactical
pressure now is on Andre
you'll see the critical penetration of
the jaw with the wrist yeah wow yeah
I'll go in the legs for a one-handed
strangle
foreign
very bravely
but
a strangle it doesn't matter how Brave
you are and where where does the
strangle actually happen in terms of
um
it felt like the strangle was at the
blade of the it wasn't even fully sunk
in yeah so where does is that the
fulcrum was like um one-handed there's a
sense in which once you get underneath
you know the inevitable yeah follow-up
position because again the inevitable
you're feeling the inevitable it's like
a um to go back to your chest analogy
it's like resigning in jizz yeah and
chess is considered almost like impolite
to let let it run out when you
understand yeah when you understand the
death is
on the horizon
and there's a lot of
there's a lot of respect that was the
beautiful thing with all the trash talk
and everything like that Gordon always
shows respect I love that
um about the drama of combat
is trash talk in the beginning and
respect at the end I think it's you know
when you when you feel someone uh Andre
has great skills and uh when you when
you grapple someone you feel just how
skilled they are and um uh it whatever
issues you had prior to the match
evaporate when you when you feel that
okay they're just like you they do the
same moves and same kind of Concepts and
and you see that there's more that bonds
you together than separates you and
that's the feeling that the end of most
grappling matches